négligence criminelle violation du droit
à la vie et entrave à l'enquêté ce sont
les accusations portées ce mardi 3 août
par human rights watch à l'encontre des
autorités libanaises à la veille du
funèbres premier anniversaire de
l'explosion qui a dévasté le port de
beyrouth le 4 août 2020 lo ng recommande
non seulement une mission
d'investigation de l'onu mais aussi des
sanctions internationales envers de
hauts responsables libanais plusieurs
autorités libanaises ont été au minimum
criminellement négligente en vertu de la
loi libanaise dans leur gestion de la
cargaison en créant un risque
déraisonnable pour la vie humaine
certains responsables gouvernementaux
ont anticipé et accepté tacitement les
risques de décès posés par la présence
de nitrates d'ammonium dans le port dans
la législation nationale
cela est susceptible de constituer un
crime d'homicide avec intention probable
et ou d'homicide involontaire en vertu
du droit international des droits de
l'homme
l'incapacité d'un et à agir pour
prévenir des risques prévisibles pour la
vie viole le droit à la vie comment des
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium se sont
elles retrouvées dans le port de
beyrouth qu'est ce qui a déclenché
l'incendié à l'origine de l'explosion
pourquoi ce nitrate d'ammonium
etait-il stockés dans un entrepôt d la
dre à ces questions aucune réponse n'a
encore été apportée au cours de cette
année d'en quête à la mi juin
cinquante trois ong ont réclamé qu'une
enquête soit menée par l'onu
le 2 août dernier c'est amnesty
international qui a accusé les autorités
libanaises de sabots telle enquête
les autorités libanaises ont promis
qu'une enquête allait être promptement
menée en raison de façon éhontée bloqué
et retardé le cours de la justice à
maintes reprise malgré l'un la sable
campagne pour la justice et la reddition
de comptes mené par des victimes et des
familles de victimes
malgré les mises en garde répétées de
and jëf jël enquête n'avance pas le 10
décembre 2020 hassan diab le premier
ministre démissionnaire ainsi que trois
anciens ministres sont inculpés par le
juge fadi sawan en charge de l'enquêté
sur l'explosion de des ministres accusés
réclame la récusation du juge
l'enquète est suspendu une semaine plus
tard fadi sawan le juge est ensuite
récusé le 18 février dernier par la cour
de cassation qui nomme à sa place tard à
guitare ce dernier a annoncé début
juillet son intention de demander des
comptes
hassan diab et a exhorté le parlement a
levé l'immunité de trois députés et
anciens ministres afin je cite
d'intenter des poursuites pour potentiel
intention d'homicide et négligence et
manquement
le parlement réclame plus de preuves
mais tariq bitar rejette cette demande
depuis c'est le statu quo l' enquête
serait au trois quart achevé selon une
source judiciaire citée par la fp
d'après l'agencé un document interne de
la sûreté de l'état datant de plusieurs
mois avant l'explosion indiqué que des
matières dangereuses étaient stockés
dans un entrepôt et alertait sur les
risques d'un énorme incendie qui
pourrait presque entièrement détruire le
port aujourd'hui hassan diab est
toujours inculpé et 18 personnes sont en
détention dans le cadre de la sphère